all right so two cups of flour and this
is uh this is the the allpurpose gold
metal flour it's not uh that glutenfree
save the [__]
whs whatever the hell it is it's like
look you're making a pot already you
know what I mean it's not going to be
helpful just give it to that just tell
yourself you're going to go to the gym
so there's two cups of this and you also
put salt in it so you just go like this
is what I you take the one cup dump it
like that there's your one cup where the
hell's my salt right here then I put the
salt right over there you getting that
are you getting that you put the salt
just like that that for [__] sakes dump
it on top of like that
right boom see you're done with that you
take this thing here you just all you're
doing is going like this I don't know
why you do this but look at see how it's
in there it looks a little different
there right that's a little more 6y